sweet Mary Jane is my vice so your boys
on the other hand is and always has been
the destroyer of worlds you're out of
touch and I would like you to consider
an offer it's the kind of guy Richie
project that I enjoy the most that he
does lock stock and snatch it's those
small crime worlds with different very
idiosyncratic characters who were the
masters of their own universe or at
least seemed to be or believe they are
it was that that world when I read the
script that's why I said okay I'm gonna
work with guy this is the the milieu the
the the palette I want to work with him
in yeah I mean if it felt like a dream
come true for me because I you know I
felt like looking back on you know the
years that I was you know aspiring you
know to do this for for a job I'd lock
stock was like one of the ultimate films
for me and so to work you know to have
that opportunity to work with guy was
was incredible and in that particular
genre I mean my my audition really was
going around a guy's house and having a
whiskey with him yeah you know and I
think he's one of those directors that
when he when he clicks with with an
actor because he knows how he works and
and that's you know getting onto set and
everything absolutely changing so you
need to be a be pliable and he needs to
be able to see that he can work with you
for me it was you know after after that
sort of morning it was just like man it
was it would be a dream come true to be
on the project so yeah I was happy to be
bored I would see that he was slightly
more eccentric and we was on the mound
from uncle on this
he was pretty eccentric on that with his
private dining table with a white cloth
being brought to the set and delicious
food strange hours of the day and he was
dressed then head to foot in tweed in
Rome in 80 degrees and on this one he
has a do to his trailer yeah he has a
beautiful trailer
like a normal one from the outside and
on the inside it's some a log cabin
somewhere in Canada with a wood-burning
stove and full of people people I put my
own who they were not associated with
the film no no no he rolls he rolls deep
oh guy for me the process is always kind
of unexpected and can be magical can be
very very challenging
he's very material guy so something that
he's absolutely in love with the day
before and you'll say so I'm gonna go
home and prep the scene tonight so
anything that you're thinking might not
work or you're gonna want to change it
no I absolutely love it and then you'll
show up the next day and say you know I
looked at that scene again it's terrible
what kind of rewrite everything right
now you think okay this let's see where
this goes but you know he has an
unbelievable ability to work in real
time you know I think he's extraordinary
I mean wherever his inability to prep
which is pretty significant his ability
to work very efficiently in real time is
pretty extraordinary so just keeps you
on your toes right yeah I want you to
play a game with me ray I don't want to
play a game oh please no I said playing
game with me right right lovely our
gentleman never tells
I think for some of us just born a
gentleman look I think it's home others
not it's harder for Charlie it is Liz
darling thank you thank you for thank
you for acknowledging that and there
were a lot gents on this set no guys are
real you know he's a rodent he's always
in a snappy suit Oh Burke I mean they
were all now I can't be specific about
the heroes and zeros but our protagonist
is a hungry animal
no no didn't oh he he grabbed my prop
joint put a Snooper whatever an 8-minute
seen until that joint was gone
and right at the end I go and he goes
yeah until the next eight hours were
quite entertaining in a different way
where none of the dialogue that was
written was said Wow if you smell smoke
it's because there's a fire do you get a
stamp that how quickly it was great I
mean that scene was a lot of fun and on
page it you know it was something that I
was really excited about doing you know
I think the dialogue was you know it's
so punchy and there's this sort of kind
of ping pong going on between them but
it was great but we weren't sort of
expecting we didn't know how it would
sort of unfold you know it was in the
script that you know he eventually she
runs out of the tiny bullets and he
attacks her but we didn't really know
where it was going so they brought on
the stunt doubles who then were like
throwing each other across the the room
and every it's gonna play out
but it's you know with guy it's very you
know changes a lot so you you really
sort of have to be on your toes and it's
a lot of fun you know I for an actor I'd
you know I I'm sure you'd both agree I
think it's it felt really refreshing
actually to do something that wasn't so
regimented and kind of on the it changes
and actually that it's a real challenge
as an actor you know to just kind of do
it on the spot and tagging explodes on
the scene back a Millenial fire
and has indirectly started a war we're
about halfway through where we just
moved we company moved to Japan
it's an origin story I can't say too
much about it but it really delves into
the character behind the mask and really
sort of establishes who he is as a
person which which I think people were
hungry for and it's such an iconic
character you kind of want to know more
not you know not just the weapon that he
is but why is he the way that he sort of
became and rubbish Frankie my director
is has is such a Japanese sort of cinema
file that he's integrated a lot of sort
of the curse ours kind of I suppose
flavor and and I suppose creating
something that we're not used to on
screen and I think it's it's a far throw
from the general sort of kind of
superhero movie and something a lot more
sort of based in reality so it's it's a
special on man these people are gonna
clean house and you are part of that
house in the jungle only way a lion
survives I did know that I'm extremely
proud I know a hundred percent red ones
and this you know having had I think
eight percent on Rotten Tomatoes with
one film that I shan't mention it was a
lovely boost what's the lowest you've
had tomato meter I damn it go on to
check I do know that guy an eyes first
film together was 23% British it which
is pretty unfresh yeah we don't blame
you though you just compiled the data
it's hard not to blame you and you know
you're very resentful of your site's
ability to shine a very bright light on
our failures but
we don't so thank you for your service
[Music]